6 24 on your wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy how about the ghost
of project neon making a brief
appearance this weekend
you know back when the remake of the
i-15 was going on through the spaghetti
bowl we had a lot of closures of the ram
from the 95 south to the south
15. well the nevada department of
transportation is doing it again
scheduling an eight-hour closure of not
just that ramp but others in the area as
well
this is going to be on sunday from six
in the morning scheduled to last until
two in the afternoon crews
are going to be replacing a damaged
crash barrier and
three other ramps are affected that
includes the
southbound 95 collector road that starts
at decatur although the exits to both
decatur and valley view will stay open
also closed the ramp to get out of the
south 95 from valley view
and the south 95 off ramps to both
rancho and mlk will be closed
now the 95 itself will stay open and
that includes the hov flyover from the
south 95 to the south 15.
it's a lot to take in all of this is on
our website eightnewsnow.com you just
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully and please put
down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com